up until the 1970s cryptography had been
based on symmetric keys that is the
sender encrypts their message using a
specific key and the receiver decrypts
using an identical key as you may recall
encryption is a mapping from some
message using a specific key to a cipher
text message to decrypt the cipher text
you use the same key to reverse the
mapping so for Alice and Bob to
communicate securely they must first
share identical keys
however establishing a shared key is
often impossible if Alice and Bob can't
physically meet or requires extra
communications overhead when using the
diffie-hellman key exchange plus if
Alice needs to communicate with multiple
people perhaps she's a bank then she's
going to have to exchange distinct keys
with each person now she'll have to
manage all of these keys and send
thousands of messages just to establish
them could there be a simpler way in
1970 James Ellis a British engineer and
mathematician was working on an idea for
non-secret encryption it's based on a
simple yet clever concept lock and
unlock are inverse operations Alice
could buy a lock keep the key and send
the open lock to Bob Bob then locks his
message and send it back to Alice no
keys are exchanged this means she could
publish the lock widely and let anyone
in the world use it to send her a
message
and she now only needs to keep track of
a single key Alice never arrived at a
mathematical solution though he had an
intuitive sense of how it should work
the idea is based on splitting a key
into two parts an encryption key and a
decryption key the decryption key
performs the inverse or undo operation
which was applied by the encryption key
to see how inverse keys could work let's
do a simplified example with colors how
could Bob send Alice a specific color
without Eve who is always listening
intercepting it the inverse of some
color is called a complementary color
which when added to it produces white
undoing the effect of the first color in
this example we assume that mixing
colors is a one-way function because
it's fast to mix colors and output a
third and it's much slower to undo Alice
first generates her private key by
randomly selecting a color say red next
assume Alice uses a secret color machine
to find the exact complement of her red
and nobody else has access to this
this results in cyan which she sends to
Bob as her public key let's say Bob
wants to send a secret yellow to Alice
he mixes this with her public color and
sends the resulting mixture back to
Alice now Alice adds her private color
to Bob's mixture this undoes the effect
of her public color leaving her with
Bob's secret color notice Eve has no
easy way to find Bob's yellow since she
needs Alice's private red to do so this
is how it should work however a
mathematical solution was needed to make
this work in practice